be welcome and thank you for joining our
first virtual Innovation Summit we have
a truly Global audience uh views of
today going from across the world and
you know in today's unprecedented times
it's really quite acceleration of us to
come together as a life sciences
Community to address the impacts of the
pandemic and other Health crisis you
know Thelma Fisher has been a proud
partner with key thought leaders and
innovators who will be presenting their
progress they have made over the
different life science application areas
in this power pack three-day event
this keynote is slightly different than
normal it's been more of a conversation
around a few topics with some of my
colleagues but I would like introduce
so today we'll be talking to Dr Andreas
humor who's the senior director of life
science Brad Hart who's our director of
clinical research in life sciences mass
spectrometry and Steve million who is
part of our viral Vector Services Group
the Pharma Services team so we're having
a conversation with these three
colleagues during the journey here
through this presentation
you know innovation has been the heart
of the mass spectrometry
business producing high performance
systems and very key Milestones even
though this map goes back to 2005
obviously film official was innovating
in Mass spectrometry for many many years
before that where there was a
single-stage protocol
2D 3D iron traps ftms yeah all the
traffic was really an inflection point
in terms of the major applications that
were enabled use that technology so if
you hop back to 2005 which is now 16
years ago you know the first ldq
orbitratma spec was really the first
system that allowed comprehensive single
shot analysis of say that the uh by
bacterial proteome over the next six
years we developed the number of systems
right around that technology but then in
2011 I think one of the most impactful
launches with the Q executive which is
the first benchtop Ms hybrid Ms which
down and bottom up proteomics and really
have significant impact and you can see
the different figures of merits there in
terms of the The Sciences enabled I
think importantly in 13 the orbitraft
fusion tribory Mass spectrometer was
launched and this is really a Quantum
step in terms of throughput and
improving throughput the sample
multiplexing along with things like TMT
reagents which we'll talk about later on
subsequently there was a number of other
tribers launched over the next seven
years as you all familiar with with the
orbitrap lumos and the more recently the
eclipse we also tried to enable the OB
traps to enter New Market spaces so the
uhmr was uh launched in
2019 whereas a platform to gain
structural insights so we instead of the
mass range of that system to 80 000 M
over Z which allowed us to look at
intact proteins and really enabled the
whole area of native proteomics to
become a more accessible technology and
an application area
not forgetting small molecules in 19 we
also enlarged the idx tribute Ms and
we'll talk some more about them a little
later on which is really a tailored
tribe system for looking at small
molecules reducing structural analysis
and different types of applications but
that's in scientific research or
toxicology or metabolomics and then of
course over the last two years we
launched the ovichap Explorers spec
family the 120 the 240 and the 480.
which really enabled uh you know
high-speed analysis and adoption into
new application spaces whether that's in
the more applied areas environmental
toxicology food and then really opened
up the proteomics the metabolomic space
together with speed and resolution and
sensitivity
I think what's stunning is um is always
this slide which we've shown every year
is the amount of Publications that come
out of the uh all the traffic family so
in the last 12 years there's actually
been over 75 000 articles published
amazing so on the left-hand side you can
see all the journals and you can then on
the right
the pace of the publishing of those
papers
asked you if you really put the math on
that it's one and a half articles or
published every hour which is truly
stunning for that technology the impact
it's had on the on the industry and the
community
I think if you reflect on uh Therma
Fisher Scientific during this recent
pandemic
you know we have a number of other
technologies that have played a role in
the um in the pandemic and understanding
of the covid-19 virus and uh here's a is
a busy slide but it shows how a prior
electron Mass my microscopy and also a
mass spectrometry have come together to
solve different problems and that may be
looking at Spike structure maybe mapping
recombinant Spike like a proteins
binding acids for targets
um you know anti-virals structural
confirmation glycosylation you can see
the map here so significant contribution
from the community in terms of
understanding of structure but also in
terms of developing therapies for the
disease so thinking about virus
structure host cell interactions virus
selling Machinery disease mechanisms and
vaccine development has been very very
important part of the work that's been
done in film official scientific with
the with the community
you know I think in addition to the
effectiveness of current drugs and
Biotherapeutics they're assessed along
with the immune system response
prognostic phenotyping direct rapid
virus development an average a
publication submission was made
approximately every other day when
covid-19 research with our very own
orbitrat Mass spectrometers
and you can see that in this this graph
here and these are all peer-reviewed
journals and like I said if you look at
hostile interactions as these mechanisms
and Drug development virus detection
varicellular machine or you can see the
the distribution of papers that were
published throughout the last year using
mass spectrometry for covid-19 studies
with that said uh let's dig deeper to
understand the role of mass spectrometry
in the pandemic at this point I'm
pleased to introduce Andres humor of
senior director of omics in
chromatography and Mass spectrometry a
division of selfish scientific you'll
begin this this discussion
so Andreas a question for you um Master
Geometry is a powerful Tool uh for
infectious disease research but really
not often thought of the mainstream
technology in this field from the
perspective how is the role of the MS
evolved during the pandemic
yeah yeah thanks for having me the
instant response to the covid-19
Challenge from the scientific community
that we witnessed was something I'd
never seen in my career before
the entire field pivoted to apply their
field of expertise and their resources
to answer the critical questions that we
needed to respond to to the to the
pandemic
the Olympics and the mass spectrometry
Community was no different from a
scientific perspective that meant we
have to quickly understand the structure
of the virus particularly the spike
protein that enables the access axis of
the virus to the human body
weeks after the threat was identified
the first structures were published
using cryelectron microscopy and Mass
spectrometry
characterizing the important viral
structures that ultimately enabled the
successful creation of a vaccine it's
now being rolled out worldwide
but almost in Peril however laughs
across disciplines collaborated to get a
deeper understanding of the biology of
infection in the host response again
Mass spectrometry was a key tool to
study the interactions
uh of viral proteins with host proteins
and now we have several research
Publications that describe how the virus
proteins interact with the host proteins
to Target innate Community regulators
and interrupt potential viable protein
phosphorylation signaling Pathways to
down-regulate type 1 interference
response from The Host
so in those research efforts many
potential drug targets were discovered
and the work now offers the opportunity
to repurpose some of the existing drugs
for antiviral Therapeutics
I believe there are now over 130
potential Direction debates in clinical
trials and again this very deep insight
to the biology of covid-19 was made
possible by the enormous Discovery power
of Overture high resolution Mass
spectrometry
now from a technology solution provider
perspective
the covid-19 crisis has challenged
organizations like Thomas Fisher
Scientific in ways we have never
anticipated
we have to respond quickly to support
vaccine development and Manufacturing
through Mass spectrometry
Ian I know that we have to specifically
develop tools for that
yes correct it was really exciting to
see the application of mass spectrometry
uh using our other track HRM instruments
but the story does not stop with our
instruments so it really extends to our
software Solutions as well
you know our film official scientific
biopharma
software it's 4.1 which we'll be talking
about this this next week as a
capability to analyze uh digested mRNA
optimizative identifying HMR and
digestion component based upon in
Silicon digestion so as in Silicon
digestion of large MRI there's automated
components and modification detection
automated msno sanitation for identical
components and visual mapping tools
provide the percent sequence coverage
you know these new capabilities combined
with our HRM Mass effects providing an
invaluable tool for mRNA research in the
past year and this new MRA mapping
capability is the first to Market
solution for lcms analysis so very very
important combination of both Mass
spectrometry hardware but also software
to solve a very important problem and
look at new therapeutic modalities
you know you know further Downstream one
of the most widely used methods as you
all know is to do text um bowel
infection in the diagnostic real-time
polymerase Chain Reaction rotpcr however
because of covid-19 pandemic Mass
metronic proteomics was actively being
discussed the potential diagnostic
method for viral infections and although
proteomics is not yet applied in routine
virus Diagnostics there is huge
potential for two applied to detect
viral infections let's learn a bit more
about this from Brad hot our senior
director of clinical research and
toxicology in the chromatography Mass
Effect division
so Brad uh you know a significant
percentage of the Publications or
related to direct coveted identification
as for traumetry you know what has led
our customers to see covid-19 using mass
spectrometry what do we learned about
the future of mass spectrometry and
infectious disease testing and kind of
Diagnostics
thank you for the question in in the
last year Thermo Fisher received over 40
requests to collaborate on code ID
testing by mass spec everything from
compact sniffers to large scale
lab-based automation platforms the nih's
Radix proposal kicked off a rush of
innovative ideas primarily around
accurate fast easy to use and widely
accessible
testing in a variety of matrices however
some of the Innovation proposals
actually tapped into existing clinical
Logistics chains using nasopharyngeal
swabs and then deploying Mass Spec as
the detection technology as stated and
published by Dr pandiam Mayo Clinic here
in Europe the covid-19 Mass Effect
Consortium assay was considered by the
UK NHS as one alternative to deploy the
use of mass spec on a large scale in
other parts of Europe we're also
involved with the covid-19 mass spec
Consortium in this regard
so why was mass spec so heavily pursued
for covid-19 ID for one it is an
alternative supply chain to PCR and the
PCR supply chain was stretched at the
height of the pandemic also since Mass
Spec is routinely used in clinical labs
and the coveted testing by PCR reduced
the usage of those instruments towards
their traditional Mass Spec test a
capacity opportunity existed in the labs
and covid-19 mass spec assays were
primarily focused on the identification
of the nuclear capsid protein proteins
are stable anilines it's an attractive
attribute for a robust clinical assay
uh the preparation costs are similar or
less than PCR reagents and as a leader
in proteomics of the invention with over
70 000 Publications on the orbit trap
um those included viral studies on SARS
cov1 MERS Kobe and other infectious
disease it comes in no surprise that our
customers would quickly quickly
recognize the potential for Rapid
identification of the coveted virus with
mass spec
the 16 papers were accepted in the last
year on covid-19 identification by mass
spec we know that the selectivity of
mass spec is unsurpassed and we verified
in this effort that the sensitivity
can be equal to PCR even at low viral
loads we confirmed throughput can be as
fast as a sample per minute or better we
know that it is straightforward to
Multiplex analytes with Mass Effect
towards larger disease panels and the
interest in Mass Effect being closer to
the patient grows yearly
it's still a major challenge as mass
spectrometry is considered a complex
technology for clinical labs
so where do we go from here where do we
go next
in the last year our customers have
demonstrated the ability to Pivot and
rapidly to develop mass spec assays for
infectious disease in response to the
covid-19 crisis
the work done in 20 and 21 Builds on the
foundation to effectively apply Mass
Spec to infectious disease
identification as well as provide the
capability for phenotypic prognostic
information
first treatment treatment stratification
some aspect also offers fast selective
potential for diagnosis of infectious
disease panels which do have added
utility for clinical Diagnostics we can
imagine a single analysis for the
detection and confirmation of common
cold influenza variants COV variants and
even tuberculosis
and I'll just say that tuberculosis
being preventable and treatable it still
infects 25 percent of the world's
population and is one of the leading
infectious disease killers in the world
taking the lives of 1.6 million people
each year
so we will continue to develop and
expand protein assays towards the clinic
in support of lab developed tests with
capillary and analytical flow rates as
fully integrated workflows and even
towards Rapid analyzers we will continue
to develop and expand ivd approved Mass
Spec platforms we registered our triple
quads in 20 countries last year
and we'll continue to develop mass
spectrometers that can be deployed
closer to the patient
and we truly see infectious disease
identification and confirmation as a
critical opportunity for the Mass Effect
Community to make the world a healthier
and safer place thank you Ian
so thanks Brad for that Insight that was
very very helpful
so along with our Partnerships through
the outside of the community we have
also found it with internal groups
inside some official scientific
um to optimize services for the
pharmaceutical industry and I'd like to
introduce Stephen million from a
pharmaceutical Services Group and how
they've worked with their clients to
optimize their bioelectric services it's
assuming a number of questions here
um you discuss cell and gene therapy
overall missionaround offering lcms
Based Services
great thank you Ian for that
introduction
um really the overall mission uh around
offering Elsewhere lcms based Services
uh for our clients is really about just
utilizing the full potential of lcms
Technologies to help solve some of the
difficult challenges that the industry
is facing
when attempting to characterize these
very large complex viral Vector drug
products
also as part of this mission is to help
further standardize analytical methods
used in the industry via Publications
and the commercialization of assays and
kits
so what do you think our current clients
uh assay challenges are
that's a great question Ian I think you
know some of the greatest challenges
that we and our clients face uh uh with
regards to essays is really around
developing uh accurate precise methods
for characterizing our analytes of
Interest
the industry is really uh currently
trying to leverage uh proven analytical
methods including Mass Spec which were
widely used in in the biologics industry
and in the mab industry for the last
several decades
uh I think another big challenge uh we
face is with the consistent Supply and
quality of reagents and standards
uh and lastly there's a considerable
challenge around data integrity and
better CFR 20 21 part 11 compliance when
it comes to instrument software and data
analysis
okay
my final question is you know how did
your team internment accelerate their
offering to adapt to a specific client
needs
yeah as part of overcoming uh some of
the challenges I just mentioned um and
doing it in an accelerated way has been
to make strategic investments in the
latest lcms Technologies we've also
partnered up uh as you mentioned earlier
and we've partnered up with other
internal groups within thermal uh uh to
to try to develop uh novel approaches
for characterizing viral vectors and
process related impurities
so Stephen what was the downstream
impact to our clients
uh feedback thus far from clients has
been extremely encouraging
um our clients also see the advantages
in leveraging these very powerful
analytical methods
um you know we now have the ability to
use the most advanced instrumentation
and Analysis to better characterize our
clients drug products
we are also exploring uh ways to provide
products such as sherquan kits to
further standardize and streamline
assays for viral Vector products
uh this will have a huge benefit for our
clients as it will dramatically reduce
the time needed for assay development
and inevitably it will also reduce the
the time needed for release of drug
batches
yeah thanks dude that's a powerful
example about how must the Trump should
based proteomics is having direct impact
in the electrical Sciences area shock on
technology and deployment near example
you know came out a major advance in the
podium field and has been driving the
past decade so a nice example of how
we've been able to find an adjacent
application and the biofilmer area so
the other area that's capturing
researchers imagination is around single
cell proteomics which seems to be on the
cusp of being accessible to more
researchers and not just a niche
research application
we know this research variable makes
significant contributions to cancer
research to be able to look at single
cells and study single diversity
so Andres I'll bring you back in here
can you tell us about the progress here
and what's happening in the field
yeah yeah uh signal set analysis has
been a field predominantly driven by the
scalability of genome mixed Technologies
and as you said
non-genomic Technologies are now quickly
progressing to the point where a
meaningful number of proteins can be
Quantified and studied
so we're talking about more than 20 100
proteins from a single isolated cell
there are several key technologies that
are coming together to enable this
progress uh we will hear about
commercial solutions for for sample
handling in a station session later this
week by Urban shuf
cells which would be useful in studying
rare cells for example but also the
ability to provide scale and the
throughput to study several hundred
cells per day
multiplexing is obviously the strategy
that provides the throughput that
ultimately enables studies across entire
tissue sections where researchers hope
to learn about cell heterogeneity and
cellulite connectivity in the context of
a disease such as cancer
multiplexing capabilities and
sensitivity of the mass spectrometer at
a single cell level are key for
significant findings Beyond one side of
the time and that will enable real
biological understanding uh from higher
throughput signal for profiling and
quantitation to spatialomics
I'm very excited to see how quickly this
field is discolor writing from the first
publication in 2017 uh from Lab
identifying hundreds of protein
in a non-ocytic mammalian cells
using orbital Mass spectrometer and the
continued growth of applications from
the community using overtrep Mass
spectrometers
we are dedicated to driving the progress
in single cell proteomics in making this
accessible to everyone
we will do this by partner partnering
with the thought leaders and
practitioners practitioners from both
the scientific community and bringing in
our experts in r d and application teams
to harness the insights Innovations from
both sides from ideation to development
and drive drive Delivery Solutions be it
technology which also includes sample
preparation and handling applications
and methodologies for single cell
proteomics
so we talk about cancer here and and
biomarker research is has been an area
of proteomic student is focused on for
some time now so Andreas how do you see
this of Ms evolving as a key technology
in the area of proteomics particularly
in how new technologies are applied to
translational space and in the clinical
research applications
Mass spectrometers often seen as a
specialized expert technology
particularly by scientists in the
clinical translational research space
where standardization and scalability
are required
in the biomarker field plasma has been a
tissue of choice
and the programming field has focused
for a long time on providing depth of
protein coverage for most complex
protein mixtures that we know of which
is plasma
of course this has meant in the past
that ultimately research researchers had
to trade off between thought throughput
and Discovery power
more recently however there has been a
rethinking in the field and researchers
are focused on scalability providing
higher throughput with enough Discovery
power that other Technologies cannot
provide
we will hear more in our Trends and life
science omics research opening keynote
on Thursday from our partners and
Industry leaders on how we are advancing
deep rapid large-scale proteomics
utilizing orbital Mass spectrometer and
no novel sample preparation Technologies
I would say plasma proteomics is
crossing the chasm
so so speaking of crossing the chasm are
those advances primarily driven by
sample preparation Technologies are we
seeing other Technologies emerging to
drive those breakthroughs
advances in Sample preparation are
needed to drive standardization across
the workflow and we have launched a
number of relevant consumable products
in this space over the past few years to
help standardization and automation
but in addition to generating more
useful data data analysis tools have
evolving out of deep learning efforts
are now providing a complete new level
of spectrum analysis that were
Unthinkable just a few years ago
on Thursday I encourage you all to join
the session by Martin freno who will
show how artificial intelligence is
transforming proteomics data analysis
so how are the translation methods
progressing in other omics such as small
molecules
um I.E metabolomics
meets for standardization and
scalability are pretty much the same in
metabolomics
but the difference that standardization
of metabolic's approaches for plasma
analysis has not progressed as much
compared to proteomics
to really help to write this process in
the community we're very much involved
in the qcqa efforts of the community the
M clock group
we recently partnered with UC Davis West
Coast metabolomic Center to form a
center of clinical metabolomics with
Professor Oliver Feen to help drive fast
practices and unlock the power of
standardized workflows around the
orbitrap technology in a number of
large-scale studies
over the past several years we have been
working hard to enable the use of mass
spectrometer
technology to non-expert users
this intelligent Mass spectrometry
methods that we introduced several years
ago are good examples of that and have
helped to drive adoption in an automated
democratization in metabolomics
uh example you might be the acquired X
data acquisition workflow approach we
launched several years ago
has enabled non-experts to gain a depth
of coverage from complex samples that
was not possible before
motivations around the topic of
intelligent mass spectrometers will be
forward coming forward in the future
that will continue to drive
democratization in the space of all
makes
thanks Andres for that Insight that was
very very helpful so I hope you've
enjoyed our conversation as much as we
have and how we're shaping the future of
lcms and lifetime since community so far
you know without
asking about the orbitrage-based
Innovations I'm sure you're wondering
what other Innovations we've been
working on during the last year during
the pandemic okay for um for small
molecule and non-analysis the primary
goals are to detect compounds of
interests and understand their structure
you know the elucidation of chemical
structures is one of the most difficult
challenges in analytical chemistry
background and Matrix interferences can
inhibit the quality results and magnet
creating background exclusion layers and
Matrix features is labor intensive
msms is often insufficient for
structured assignment MSN can help it
requires extensive experience to set up
now there are also additional challenges
about how to best visualize the
extensive data sets and confidentially
assign matching identifying for an
unknown
now acquiring data more data is the one
part of that story but compound
identification is is the next step for
comprehensive uh
identification of volume compounds so
using a thermo scientific compound
discover software in combination with a
range of special libraries such as mg
cloud compound databases ranking tools
such as fellow scientific energy logic
can really erase on future
identification you know all this
provides extensive special Library
fragmentation information and structural
databases the small molecular research
is of high confidence in assignments for
a more unknown compounds in less time
you know as for the slide here some
official scientific developed a
comprehensive hardware and software
solution to address these challenges and
Andrea said back in 2019 we launched the
thermoscientific over chart idx which
was a dedicated trib mouse back coupled
with
tells you workflows such as acquire act
straight around position and compound
discover as a total solution for small
molecule identification to address this
identity crisis in small molecule
compound ID
if today I'm really pleased to introduce
our next generation of small molecule
dedicated tribute Mass Spec the
orbitraft iqx Tribune mass spec
the instrument has been built to help
small molecule research capture more low
abundance unknown analytes so they can
generate more meaningful data from
multiple applications whether lipidomics
metabolomics metabolite ID any other
small molecule
application as you can see compared to
his previous says there's some new
features in here notable improvements
mediq data acquisition which is now a
real-time Library search which allows us
to do confident identification of
structurally similar molecules so that
IQ there's also remote calibration with
a new order ready iron source which
allows users to spend less time on
instruments setup but it has automated
schedule calibration times as Zone
emitter it's on Sample tube to avoid
calibration
and then the overtrap iqx instrument
comes with Quirk with the enhanced deep
acquirex data acquisition so enhancing
that workflow which provides a fully
automated method to perform exhaustive
precursor selection for high quality MSN
data acquisition so now we can combine
up to five inclusion lists and exclusion
lists we can submit several experiments
from the signal sequence and as you can
see there are other features in here
which are enhancing the capability of
the small molecule analysis
talked about require extra acquisition
which is an exhausted method ology
profiling and in the real-time Library
searching which is mediq from known
identification based on a related
compounds so the two workflows acquire X
is unknown unknowns which is a workflow
looking at an exhausted methodology
looking at preeclosed to IMS accuracy
ms1
experiments and then creating user lists
for our next experiment so we can go
deep into into a sample the Met IQ is a
Known Unknown experiment where we're
looking at related compounds they're
almost a targeted experiments where we
have related compounds but unable to
distinguish by precursor Mass alone and
basically we create the MSN
fragmentation of precursor ions and we
automatically search those against
special libraries then trigger further
experiments to go and look at
substructure of related compounds
now both of these uh workflows can be
combined obviously you can use acquirex
in a real-time Library search so you can
use acquirex to remove background ions
then we can use a more targeted
experiment to look at structure related
compounds
so here's uh here's the med IQ Data
intelligent data acquisition flow for
it's an intelligent Ms for small
molecules so the challenge here is
identifying unknown metabolites that
we've done so transformation products
the solution is an intelligent Ms and
data acquisition
which enables annotation and
characterization of unknown compounds so
you can see the workflow here uh
fundamentally we take the parent drug a
pro drug which is a known compound and
create a spectral library and this may
be through multiple hcd energies it may
be through different fragmentation modes
and those are stored in the library
we then run the unknown compounds
mixture of no related compounds and we
compare the MS2 Spectra to the library
in real time
this is a similarity match we actually
trigger an ms3 experiment and we can
characterize the unknown compounds using
a combination of the MS2 and ms3 Spectra
so the workflow is smart IT triggers
very few and very selective ms3 scans
only based on MS2 spatulas similar to
those compounds of Interest
it's not a dolly smart because ms3 are
triggered on fragments they're unique to
the unknowns and it's the quickest route
to the structuralization so effectively
increasing the MS2 scan rate for
sampling more precursor Ms precursors so
this is a very very powerful and
intelligent methodology to essentially
look at compounds with special
similarity in a com in a complex mixture
okay
and here's just a real example using
intelligent ms3 with real-time Library
search you can see the Spectrum top
which is the known drug compound of
interest and we matched the MS2 Spectra
from the library to the experiment msms
of the unknowns and you can see there
there's a few Peaks that are slightly
different a lot of similarity so we
trigger ms3 and a special at the bottom
of the chemistry triggered
substructures from the msms this is a
very very powerful way of digging deeper
into Spectra and molecules of similarity
whether it's a metaboliter
transformation product and here's a real
example
um here's a real example from Genentech
it's a study of Van prevenile metabolite
identification using the new mediq
workflow so Med IQ with data dependent
triggered ms3 demonstrated 54 more
metabolites identified than traditional
experiments so the experimental
conditions you can see down the side in
comparative results were compared with a
set of previously characterizing
metabolites ms3 was triggered for 17
metabolic peaks in the mid IQ DDA versus
11 metabolites the traditional DBA
experiment so the power of this workflow
really allows us to go looking very
complex mixtures and find compounds of
similarity which would normally missed
because of the background and other
factors in in terms of the acquisition
rates that we run at
foreign
iqx is being used for a host of
applications including impurity analysis
and Med ID lipidomics or it could be on
the target metabolonics don't forget to
attend these sessions in the next two
days they'll be given by christopherden
and Scott Stanley Josh Kuhn and Gary
Patty will cover a range of different
applications using an advanced data
intelligent data acquisition
methodologies
we are also introducing the fames Duo
Pro interface which extends the
capabilities of our differential and
Mobility to a broader range of
applications and also a broader range of
flow rates
veins Pro 2 interface is an orthogonal
technology for doing gas phase
separation which reduces background
complexity and allows more selectivity
in analytical analysis so
the system here is optimal for both low
and high flow rates it now runs from 100
naniliters to one mill a minute the
interface is compatible with all our
Mass spectrometers it has online CV
optimization capabilities not only for
high resolution accurate Mouse systems
but also for triple quotes for SRM pipe
applications but also have fast CV
switching times for targeted and
quantitative applications so the famous
Pro Duo interface is really allowing
extension of our gas phase separation
capabilities for for more targeted
applications and ultimately increasing
detection limits in very complex
mixtures
there's a couple of examples here here's
an example
of the set of sulfide metrics spiked
into a meat Matrix that I'm sure
without themes there's a huge presence
of the solventions and also Coalition
Matrix signs you can see that DSC is a
very noisy background we introduce fames
selectivity we suppress both the
Abundant solvenience and the co-looking
Matrix ions and the basically tested on
the target compound which is actually a
10x fold lower intensity uh can now be
detected reproducibly and unquantified
so the power of this technology to
reduce interferences and become more
selective for target analysis analysis
allow us to get low and low detection
limits in very complex matrices
and just a second example is a targeted
Compound quantitation on a triple stage
quadrophones the tsql test looking for
testosterone and detection really
becomes a challenge when extracted from
plasma due to the background
interferences this was actually around a
250 microliters in there and the example
here reduces The Matrix interferences to
increase the signal for noise so we have
reliable detection of the compound but
also removal interference improves
automatic Peak integration to improved
confidence in the methods efficiency so
another very simple example with fames
introduces selectivity to allows us to
do high performance quantitative
analysis on a triple stage qualiform
so if you want to learn more about
either the orbitrap iqx Trib Mouse spec
or the famous Duo Pro interface our
product experts will be available
for you daily during the set of End
hours which you can see on the slide
here they look forward to chatting with
you further about these later
Innovations and getting into more
details about the scientific
applications that can be addressed with
these Technologies
so Switching gears from from lcms to
gcms earlier this year we launched a
thermosynthetic overtraf explos GC and
gc240ms
to extend the capability of ultra high
resolution GC
non-statrometry experiments you see here
this is the Explorers GC this is a full
scan high resolution system
providing accurate mass for for a series
of different types of applications the
uh the beauty of this system obviously
is through method development you spend
less time evaluating data increased
accuracy because of the high res and
accurate Mass capability that this
system provides for for a number of
different applications whether that's in
the food safety space environmental it
could be in the toxicology area the
second instrument the
gc240ms is a more advanced system the
system provides an unprecedented 240 000
resolution which provides the highest
data quality to accelerate scientific
discovery this also system has options
with flexibility so we can have direct
analysis probes you can look at the EI
and look at CI ionization and msns so it
really extends the application space and
obviously areas such as metabolomics can
benefit from the Overture t240
so proteomics technologies have really
been evolving over the last 15 years
providing more sensitivity more
quantitative capability but also
requiring more High throughput look at
things like coaching Dynamics and look
at a very large sample sets you know the
last 15 years the critical advances
instrumentation and also the development
of isobaric and the mass tags of enable
enabled more accurate High throughput
quantitative analysis of proteomes you
know the slide here really shows the
journey from
2005 where TNT to tmt6 came into play in
instrumentation uh mapping with it as
well to enable analysis to those those
TMT tags but as you see as we move
forward we move from six we move to 10
we moved to 11 we moved to 10 to 16 in
2019 and that really has advanced
capability to do really high throughput
proteome analysis and do it very
quantitatively as well
summer scientific is uh you know excited
as you can see there at the end of that
slide to introduce two new isobaric
label tags the TMC Pro uh 134c and the
TNT Pro 134 n that can be seamlessly
integrated into Intel workflows and our
current instrumentation now it's about
Series this expands the breadth of
isobaric tagging that's available from
16plex to an 18 Flex without
of quantitative performance
just down on the right hand side there
you can see a recent publication on the
TMC Pro 18 Plex which illustrates how
high multiplexing capability reduce
these data acquisition time and results
in few missing values across experiments
you know therefore you know really
increasing efficiency without loss and
quantitative performance so very very
powerful addition to our flexing
capability the TMC Pro 18 Flex tags will
be available in July this year
we'd also like to recognize the seventh
annual
some of scientific tandem Mass tag
research award this award is open to
researchers enrolled in doctoral or
postdoctoral programs the top two
recipients were selected in combination
with Thelma Fisher Scientific and
proteome Sciences the grant is awarded
based on Innovation and potential impact
of the applications proposal of using
our attendant Mass technology in
conjunction obviously with other Mass
Effect reagents the researchers research
award is eleven thousand dollars and
used to purchase eligible
thermoscientific Mass spectrometer
reagents and also CMT labeling reagents
and the two winners this year
pleased to announce is Owen OVI from the
University of Western Ontario and jizan
from the University of California in San
Diego so congratulations to both of you
for winning this this award
okay
so thanks for joining us today uh we'll
take a short break before the live q a
where we'll be excited to answer your
questions
and we hope you enjoy the next two days
as you hear from our life sciences
change makers
schedule here you'll hear a lot of talks
around
biotherapeutic analysis and also omics
and also in the healthcare area in
clinical research so before the event
ends you know don't forget to check out
the speak to an expert lounge or a
poster Hall and our resource hub for all
the product and application contents and
we truly appreciate you attending this
session today